I don't I don't want to be like upset
well I say this so give me a sec so um I
think I'm just going to move on from
this channel for now YouTube star jenna
Marbles announced on Thursday that she
is leaving the platform after facing
backlash over some insensitive videos
from her past I'm just a person trying
to navigate the world the same way that
you are so I don't always know what's
right what's wrong with the truth is and
I'm just trying my best now fans and
other content creators are weighing in
reacting to Jenna's emotional apology
feel like we're at a time where we are
purging ourselves of anything and
everything toxic let's get you up to
speed
jenna Marbles whose real name is Jenna
Mallory
broke down in tears saying she was sorry
for insensitive and unintentionally
racist content she had posted in the
past specifically videos from 2011 and
2012 including one where she slams women
who slept around another featuring a rap
song with the joke about Asians and one
where she dogs blackface to impersonate
Nicki Minaj it was not my intention to
do blackface I do want to tell you how
unbelievably sorry I am if I ever
offended you by posting this video or by
doing this impression and that that was
never my intention it's not okay it's
shameful it's awful I wish it wasn't
part of my past
Jenna shared that those videos as well
as some other content from the early
years of her channel are now private and
no longer viewable by the public for now
I don't
I just can't exist on this channel
hopefully I've taken down anything that
would upset someone and I hope you know
that that's just not my intent that's
not what I ever set out to do to hurt
anyone's feelings or to pick and you
wouldn't feel bad
now the youtuber says it's time for her
to take a step back I don't know if
that's forever
I don't know how long it's gonna be um I
just I want to make sure that the things
that I've put into the world are not
hurting anyone the 33 year old has more
than 20
million subscribers and has racked up
more than three billion views total
since she started her channel in 2010 so
naturally people had something to say
about all of that YouTube star Corinne a
cop showed her support tweeting that
Jenna is so genuine and so pure in her
intention adding that people have every
right to be upset but we should see
people for who they are today blogger
Hank green echoed those thoughts
tweeting quote I really strongly believe
that we should be judged not by how we
acted when we were ignorant but how we
responded when we were informed by that
measure jenna Marbles is head and
shoulders beyond a great many youtubers
rapper chicka hit up Twitter to back
Jenna to writing that she hopes she
comes back when she's ready quote she's
never made an apology to save face or
protect business
she's always meant to every single time
and that's indisputable Canadian YouTube
laurdiy said her heart was shattered
watching Jenna's apology and youtuber
Ricky Dillon addressed Jenna directly
tweeting you have positively impacted me
more than you'll ever know adding that
she has a genuine heart of gold and he
has so much respect for her I don't want
to put anything out in the world it's
gonna hurt anybody so I need to be done
with this channel for now or forever I
don't know so alright good talk
see you guys
[Music]